wie es sich für ein klassenlager gehört
es regnet es ist kalt
frühmorgens in birmensdorf wald
idyllisch ist anders und doch idylle ist
genau das miteinander sein und dem
schulalltag and hüpfen dass hier
zwischen pfützen auf gelernt wird das
verspielt sich dafür sorgen conny stüssi
und ihr team ohne allgemeingültiges
erfolgsrezept
also eigentlich ist jedes projekt als
leitprojekt für mich weil mir eigentlich
alle grundsätzlich immer findet die
arbeit wo wir machen ich nicht wirklich
leiden
kinder und theaterpädagogen erfinden das
stück gemeinsam in einem ideen die
theatergeschichte ist kinderleicht
senioren machen eine weltreise um eine
wette zu gewinnen
das happy end hat sich der nachwuchs
ausdrücklich gewünscht alles weitere ist
reine spielwut fernab von regeln
theater fahrwerk funktioniert als ganzes
gemeinsam spielen essen und wohnen hier
zählt das miteinander obwohl wir sind
alle zusammen
die lehrerinnen hingegen sind weit weg
in der küche eine ungewohnte rolle
das zu jene mit dem us-fonds
arbeitsfrieden sind und gut so fürs kind
am tag der aufführung ist die nervosität
groß denn trotz verkleidung der
selbstbewusste auftritt erfordert mut
150 schüler aus den parallelklassen sind
zur aufführung gekommen
denn
miteinander lernen und der routine des
schulalltags ein quäntchen idylle
entreißen
das kann man hier